in league of legends before you even get
into a game
you need to make sure that you've picked
the right summoner spells
it's basic stuff it's a pretty big deal
if you get into a game and you've
somehow picked the wrong ones
but that's exactly what a chinese pro
player did
in the lpl last week and the crazy part
is
that his team fined him an entire month
salary for this mistake
and this isn't even the first time that
something like this has happened
what is going on
okay then we cover all the biggest
scandals the craziest pop-offs
and the weirdest moments in esports just
like this one
so that all sounds like your cup of tea
then make sure you are subscribed to the
score esports and that way
you will never miss a video just like
this one all right so the player in
question
is pzx who is on the chinese pro team
victory 5 otherwise known simply as v5
now just to set a little bit of the
scene here v5 has
not been doing very well this year in
fact they sit at the very
bottom of their 17 team league with an
abysmal record
of zero wins and 13 losses
now they're not exactly the shanghai
dragons but this summer
they've undoubtedly been the worst team
in the best league
in the world across all their best of
threes they've only managed to win a
grand total
of three games that's it it's safe to
say that their season
is beyond saving but they still had the
opportunity to end their competitive
year with their heads held high
giving it their all so basically this
[ __ ] up couldn't have come
at a worse time v5 was facing off
against
sooning who were finalists at worlds
2020.
here was a chance to show that despite
their rough season they could still put
up a good fight
however the game was basically over
before it even began
okay so in league like in most esports
there's a sort of picks phase where you
choose
what champion you're gonna play and what
similar spells you want to use
flash is almost always the most
important summoner spell to take
it allows you to blink over walls engage
onto enemies or escape
quickly from them it basically doesn't
matter what champion you're playing
you usually just take flash there are a
few exceptions to that of course
most notably at the minute is gwen top
who takes tp
and ignite but generally speaking you
just take flash
just lock it in you can even argue the
whole game is balanced around it
now your second summoner spell depends
on your role top takes teleport
eddie carrey takes peel or cleanse etc
etc but there is one spell for one role
that is undoubtedly the most important
in the entire game
the jungler takes smite it's that simple
while other roles get their golden xp
from lane minions the jungler
exclusively farms jungle monsters across
the map
as a jungler you can use smite on those
monsters to deal true damage to them it
also allows you to buy the jungle
specific
item at the start of the game which
gives you more damage against them and
60
more xp from killing them not only that
smite can deal a lot of damage to epic
monsters such as
baron and dragon so it's crucial for
getting the last hits on them
and giving your team the massive buffs
that they provide
i mean i really don't know how else to
say this but if you're a jungler who
doesn't take smite
it's either your first day playing the
game or you're literally trolling
so where do you think the last place is
that you'd expect to see a jungler not
take smite
well how about in an actual pro game in
the strongest
league of legends region in the world
how about that
during champion select we can see psx
lock in viego but at first
the casters don't notice anything
strange and to be honest you can't
really blame them
some regions like north america's lcs do
actually show what some of the spells
the players have locked in
right here you can see tsm speaker and
c9 blabber with smite equipped
but if we go back to the v5 game in
china you can see that they don't show
the summoner spells here at
all the lpl production team probably
thought it wasn't worth them taking up
any screen space because they're pretty
predictable and
surely nobody is gonna [ __ ] up their
summoner spells in a pro game right
anyway the casters didn't realize that
something had gone seriously wrong until
the players were
already into the game pzx had taken
flash
and teleport or tp instead of flash and
smite
when the casters finally realized their
reaction just said it all
i'm really confused go on why does pzx
have tp
and a no smile oh no
oh no oh my god i didn't even notice
that what
what happened now if you don't know
league you quite fairly might be
thinking
what's the big deal here surely it's not
gg already
well no it's not but pzx was going to
have a way slower jungle clear
way less xp and be unable to help his
team fend off ganks from the enemy
jungler
a domino effect had begun this has to be
a mistake right
i mean i haven't seen this if this is a
mistake i'm assuming this is a mistake i
don't know why you'd ever do this to
yourself because
he's not going to hit level 2 of this
blue buff he you can't
you can't hit level that has to be and
he has to go dormant oh my god it's 100
a mistake but
as per the rules ladies and gentlemen if
you're wondering oh he made a mistake
why aren't they resetting
you as the player are in charge of your
runes and masteries and your summoner
spells
if you don't change it in time that's on
you son that is
that is just oh that's that hurts that
hurts my soul
he's right they'll restart a game if
there's a bug or a connection issue
but failing to do what you literally
learn in week one of playing the game
sorry mate you gotta play it out the
cast has debated about whether this was
some wacky strategy that v5 was going to
use to finally win their first game of
the summer but as psx got battered in
his own jungle
it became very clear that it was just
the cock-up to end all cock-ups
to the surprise of nobody sooning
dominated the map as
v5 bled gold and xp everywhere resulting
in a 27 minute game in which v5 only
managed to get a single
sad kill copper lining this is rock
bottom for v5
it comes
only uphill from this point and i have a
very simple fix a very simple adaptation
got into that game too
for v5 take sprite in the jungle there
you go
now this was the best of three and v5
did actually win the next game but then
they lost the final one
which means this won't go down as a
heroic turnaround from a disastrous
start to the series
it's just another loss for v5 after the
game v5
fine pzx an entire month's salary for
this mistake
maybe that sounds a bit harsh to you
perhaps you've got your summoner spells
mixed up in a game before
i certainly have but you have to
remember that these are professional
players who are paid to play
they're expected to get the very basics
right especially before they even get
into a game
so how did this mistake even happen well
psx
was reportedly playing league on his
professional account
before the game and have been using
flash and teleport for a different role
and then when he got into the pro game
he simply forgot to pick up smite again
when jungling now i'd love to drive home
my point about how crazy this is by
saying that this stuff
never happens but i can't actually say
that
because it also happened last year in
the lpl once again
e-star esports jungler way forgot to
take smite during a pro game
his team got smashed as a result and he
was fined one month's wages
so yeah somehow there's even a precedent
for accidentally throwing a game before
it even starts
all in all it's a pretty funny story if
you're outside of this team
the only real talking points here are
whether or not riot should force
junglers to take smite
or perhaps restart a game if a pro
player forgets to take it i'd be
interested to know what you guys think
about that
i'm personally not a fan because this
really is such
basic stuff and sometimes it gives us
some pretty funny stories like this
prime minister boris johnson in the uk
he did an interview a while ago and
instead of saying
vegan he said vegan and it's all i can
think about he said
he said to the person interviewing him
have you ever tried one of those
vegan sausage rolls a vegan like
what [ __ ] planet are you from now i
keep forgetting how to say this word
i get this i get confused sometimes
because i know that you guys say
trolling you're lit you're literally
trolling
but i don't know that's what i'm
supposed to say